That's what I love
about money ‐‐
no emotions, no tears,
just reality.
Narrator:
It's been a remarkable 10 years.
I'm seeking a $100,000
investment...
Narrator:
Over 1,000 entrepreneurs
have walked down these halls,
seeking their piece
of the American dream.
With close to $125 million
invested in the Tank so far...
Is this gonna change the world?!
Narrator:
...and astounding successes...
We have a deal!
[ Laughter ]
Narrator:
...it ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit.
‐Whoo!
And now the Sharks are back
for an epic 10th season.
I see more beverages than
anybody else in the country.
You may not have to go out
and raise money
if you partner
with someone like me.
Narrator: And exciting titans
of business return...
I want to know a little bit
more about you.
I think that watching
"Shark Tank" as a kid
helped me be standing
in front of you all today.
We've grown up
on this show.
And remember, there's
only one Mr. Wonderful.
And thank God for that.
Narrator: ...and brand‐new
Sharks jump into the Tank.
Former NBA superstar and
broadcaster Charles Barkley
is a prolific investor
and committed
to helping entrepreneurs.
You seem to be
on the right track,
and I'm willing
to take the chance.
Narrator: Matt Higgins is Vice
Chairman of the Miami Dolphins
and is co‐founder
of RSE Ventures,
which invests in
innovative companies
across multiple sectors,
including sports,
lifestyle, and technology.
When we work together,
it's gonna be game over.
[ Cork pops, cheering ]
Narrator: And tonight,
...as we celebrate
our 200th episode ‐‐
an epic milestone ‐‐
for the first time ever, a
former "Shark Tank" entrepreneur
achieves the ultimate goal...
‐Welcome.
‐...and returns as a Shark.
"Shark Tank" has inspired
a nation to chase their dreams.
Man:
This has been a lot of my life,
and I just want to share
that with people.
There is a tenacity that I have,
and nothing's gonna stop me.
What you've done
is just inspiring.
Narrator: And the dream
continues now.
Kevin,
they say you're wrong.
I'm never wrong.
I'm always right.
I will make you
a millionaire.
Look, I'm rich.
I'm really, really, really rich.
‐Ha ha!
‐Oh, my God!
‐We got a deal!
‐Welcome to "Shark Tank".
Look, I'm just an investor
trying to scratch out
a living here, okay?
♪♪
Sharks.
Well, well, well.
Look who's back.
Narrator: Five years ago,
Jamie Siminoff
pitched the Sharks Doorbot,
which became Ring,
a smart video doorbell company.
I want a 10% royalty,
and I get 5%
of the company's equity.
Mr. Wonderful,
we're gonna decline.
Go kick some ass, Jamie.
Narrator:
Let's see what he's up to now.
Siminoff:
I was devastated walking out
of the Tank without a deal.
We needed that money
to continue to grow,
and now we didn't have it.
We got one of those royalty
offers from Kevin,
but there was no way we were
gonna be able to afford that.
But if it wasn't
for "Shark Tank,"
Ring would have never
had the exposure
that brought people like
Richard Branson in to invest
and build it into
what it is today.
As a kid, I spent a lot of time
in the basement
just building things.
I built a humane mousetrap,
a blanket to make myself colder
'cause we didn't have
air‐conditioning.
Most of them were failures.
It's a video doorbell built
for your smartphone.
I started Doorbot because
I was working in my garage,
and I couldn't
hear the doorbell,
and I thought, "Why wouldn't
the doorbell go to my phone?"
At Doorbot and Ring,
we failed many times.
What kept me going
was our mission
to reduce crime
in neighborhoods.
We knew we were doing something
better for the world,
and we wanted to continue it.
If we want to achieve that
mission, it all starts here.
It has been a really
big year for Ring.
Now Amazon is buying the company
for $1 billion.
Siminoff: What's great about
Amazon is they're gonna let Ring
still run as
an independent company
that lets me focus
on what I love ‐‐
building product and making
neighborhoods safer.
"Shark Tank" has been key to me
achieving my American dream,
and I think it's been
such a great show
for families to watch.
Kids are growing up seeing
what entrepreneurs can do,
what inventors can do, and how
you can build your own destiny.
It's amazing to think
that five years ago,
I was a broke inventor running
this business in my garage,
and today, I have the means and
freedom beyond my imagination.
Now I'm really excited for
the next chapter in my life.
‐Welcome. Welcome.
‐Welcome!
‐Hi.
‐Welcome.
I was the only one
that believed in you.
John:
Congratulations, man.
Take a seat
over here, brother.
Welcome.
Congratulations.
Congrats.
Hey, thank you.
Welcome.
‐Right here, buddy.
‐Pull up a chair.
Let's go to work.
Not bad.
You deserve your seat there.
Knock them dead.
Have fun.
Thanks, man.
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a solution
to one inconvenient aspect
of online shopping.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Brad Ruffkess.
I'm from Atlanta, Georgia,
and I'm the CEO
and founder of BoxLock.
I'm here today asking
for $1 million
‐for 5% of my company.
‐Ohh.
E‐commerce sales
are set to skyrocket
past half a trillion dollars
this year.
That means that Americans
are receiving more packages
and home deliveries
than ever before,
but there's a huge problem.
How are we going to protect
all the deliveries
from porch pirates
and package thieves?
Like millions of other people,
I had cameras installed
to be able to keep an eye on all
the deliveries we received.
Literally the very next day,
I watched some guy walk up
and steal two packages
off our front porch.
And so that's why
I created BoxLock.
BoxLock's a smart padlock.
You put it on a storage
container outside of your house.
When your friendly
delivery driver walks up,
he's gonna use the lock
to scan the tracking number
on the package.
If that package is
out for delivery to you,
the lock pops open,
giving him access.
He's gonna put the package
inside, lock it up.
You're gonna get a notification
on your phone, letting you know
that your package has been
delivered securely.
We know it's a win for anybody
who buys anything
and anybody who ships anything,
and that's why we know BoxLock
will be a win for you, too.
I'd love to share some samples
with you...
‐Sure.
‐Please.
...and answer your questions.
Thank you.
Aww, thank you.
You're such a gentleman.
You're welcome.
‐Thanks a lot.
‐Thank you.
O'Leary: So, Brad, um,
it wasn't long ago
that someone very much involved
in security
came in here and asked for
a ridiculous valuation.
I was the only Shark
that believed in him,
and now look what happened.
What happened?
He could've made
a lot of money.
‐Instead, he made some.
‐And now he's working.
[ Laughter ]
You're right
beside me now.
This is ‐‐ looks, feels
really great and solid,
so what have you
put in so far?
Where is the product
at today?
Right now, in ‐‐ in R&D,
we've probably put in, uh,
about half a million dollars.
‐Oh!
‐Wow.
It is in manufacturing
right now.
Uh, it is in the process
of shipping.
So, you haven't gotten any into
the consumers' hands yet,
but what have been
your sales?
We've actually sold 800 units
on pre‐sale.
And what were the units
being sold for?
Uh, the units at that point
were being sold between $89
to I think $109
on Kickstarter.
How much now?
Uh, so, they're gonna
retail for $129.
What's your cost
to make them?
Our next order should be
around $65 per unit.
What are you scanning?
W‐We're scanning the tracking
number on the package.
We automatically collect
tracking numbers from UPS,
USPS, FedEx ‐‐ every one
of the carriers.
How long is it gonna take
to make drivers aware
of how to use this device?
So, we're working with
the different carriers
on driver awareness
and training programs.
'Cause if this doesn't
work immediately,
they're gonna put the package
back in front of the door
and move on.
What we found is that
these guys care a lot
about making sure their
deliveries are secured.
So, why don't we just
jump right into
the looming
question here.
You want
$1 million for 5%.
That means you're saying the
company is worth $20 million.
Even the Ring guy
wasn't that aggressive.
[ Laughs ]
What's the reasoning
behind that?
This is a really complicated
problem, right,
and it needs ‐‐
it ‐‐ it needs to be solved.
Just 'cause it's a big problem
doesn't mean you get
a big valuation
for walking in.
W‐When Ring came in
at $7 million,
we were at a
$3‐plus‐million‐a‐year run rate
of sales of a product.
Yep.
So ‐‐ So, we're in market.
We're actively working
with the carriers, right.
It is all up and ‐‐ and ‐‐
and running.
So I‐I want to make
sure I understand.
I have to buy
the box first.
You have to buy a box.
Separately.
‐Yeah.
‐What's your box cost?
That box is likely gonna retail
between $100 and $129.
But why are you valuing
the business
at that price right now?
We deal in facts, today.
T‐That ‐‐
This stuff is all working.
This is ‐‐ It's ‐‐
It's all up and running.
We know all that.
‐You've already explained that.
‐Don't be ‐‐
‐I'm asking about the valuation.
‐You ‐‐ You keep explaining ‐‐
Siminoff:
You keep explaining why
the market is worth something.
Yeah, you may see it.
We need to understand why
the business is worth something.
We ‐‐ 'Cause we have
this unique opportunity
to be able to,
as I said, solve a problem
that no one else
has been able to solve.
We ‐‐ We ‐‐
But that's the reason
it's worth $20 million?
What everybody's
really wanting to hear ‐‐
No. We're waiting for real facts
like, "I have this amount of
sales, these amounts of patents.
I have th‐‐" I mean, real facts
that we can take ‐‐
S‐So let's talk
about the patents.
You know, I'm just such ‐‐ I'm
just such not‐a‐patent person.
I had no patents
protecting me.
I out‐executed.
I‐I think ‐‐ I‐I love
the market, by the way.
I mean, I‐I literally
sold my company
for over $1 billion
to Amazon,
so I know package delivery.
I control front doors.
I don't like that
you have to change
the user behavior
to do this.
You know, why Ring
worked is because
we didn't have to change
the behavior the customer.
It still was a doorbell.
It still worked.
It just enhanced it.
This changes where
you put the package,
how you deliver the package, the
timing of the package delivery.
And asking for
a $20 million valuation,
you know, it's just ‐‐ it's so
far away from me that I'm out.
Yeah, Brad, there are so many
problems that you have to solve
with so many constituents
that it's gonna cost you
hundreds of millions of dollars
and years in order
to get it done.
There's no path
of least resistance
that gets you to a‐a profitable
company that I can see.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
When I've asked you
to explain
the reason why the business
itself costs that much today ‐‐
$20 million ‐‐ you
were not able to explain that
to me in any tangible way.
S‐So, with that, I'm out.
Okay.
You know, Brad,
you're climbing Mount Everest
without an oxygen tank.
That million's gonna be
vaporized in three months
in just training costs of all
the millions of delivery guys.
Good luck on that journey.
I'm out.
‐Am I the only one left?
‐Yes, you are.
‐You're the only one left, Lori.
‐Ohh, my gosh.
Listen, QVC ships
320 million packages
a year alone.
This is a big problem.
This is a really good solution.
I've been working on something
like this now for several years.
We haven't quite come
to a finalization.
So, I will give you
the million dollars as a loan,
but I want a royalty,
and I want you to
tell me what royalty
you'd be willing
to give me.
Is your expectation
that that ‐‐
that royalty is capped at
a certain amount of sales?
Uh, I would do the royalty
until I make my money back
plus another $500.
Plus another $500,000?
Let me make sure
I get that right.
$1 million plus another $500,000
back in royalties,
so a who‐‐ total of $1.5 million
plus the interest rate?
8% interest and 2.5%
of the company in the end.
Listen, the deal ‐‐
You have learned, grasshopper,
from the master.
[ Laughs ]
I have!
I sit next to Kevin
for many, many, many years.
Cuban: So, anyways...
This is ‐‐
This is a venture‐debt deal.
But I'll tell you i‐‐
It's a venture‐debt deal.
...you u‐‐
you understand why.
Yep.
I can bring you
the customers,
but there are so many ifs here,
this is like
walking on a tightrope between
200‐story buildings.
I mean,
this is really risky.
Uh, well, so,
I greatly appreciate it.
I'd love to see if we can figure
out how to get that loan
up to $1.5 million,
and then I would love to see
the royalty at $3 per unit.
Ichiwawa. Caramba, Lori.
That's a lot of capital.
‐Boy, it's like I just...
‐Lori, Lori...
‐Really worried.
‐...come in, Lori.
Really worried. I would've
really ‐‐ They need this.
‐What are you gonna do, Lori?
‐You know...
‐So, I'm gonna throw it back
to Jamie right now.
Throw it to Jamie?
Because ‐‐ I am.
I'm gonna throw it to Jamie
because I think he'd be
a great partner.
‐Um, I do.
‐Whoa.
Jamie, I know there is no one in
this space who spent more time
than me thinking
about this problem
and trying to figure out
how to solve it.
You don't have the part
that everyone's looking for,
which is the network of these
out there in the field
and th‐‐ and that
trajectory.
You don't ‐‐
You don't have that yet.
I think that's ‐‐
that's my problem.
You're missing the part
that I would actually
be wanting to invest in.
So for that,
I ‐‐ I'm still out.
♪♪
I'm out.
O'Leary: Oh!
‐Good luck with it.
‐Good luck, Brad.
‐Congrats.
‐It's smart.
I hope ‐‐ I hope
it really works out.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Thanks, Brad.
Ruffkess: I was really,
really, really hoping
that we were gonna be able
to get to a deal with Lori.
Jamie came in here with a big
ask, and he didn't get it.
Look where he stands now.
I look forward to ‐‐ to having
the tables turned
and me sitting ‐‐ be sitting
in his chair someday.
O'Leary:
Jamie, this is all on you.
‐You killed that deal.
‐Jamie, you were out twice.
‐You got to ‐‐
‐You killed that deal.
‐You got to have ‐‐
‐[ Laughs ]
‐You know, it's c‐‐ it's cu‐‐
You crushed him.
Kevin, it's customer,
customer, customer.
All he had was product.
You know,
how the tables turn.
Yeah, right?
You pompous ‐‐
You just sat there...
Right.
...and threw that guy out
like we threw you out.
[ Laughter ]
You should be ashamed
of yourself.
‐He learned well!
‐That's unbelievable.
Boy, people
sure do change.
Greiner: Well, it was a real
flier. It was a real flier.
Jamie, you are
a dream killer.
[ Sighs ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is a young entrepreneur
who was frustrated
with a problem
he had with his favorite toy.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Tripp Phillips.
And I'm Lee Phillips,
his dad.
And this is my sister,
Allee.
We're from Dalton, Georgia,
and our company is Le‐Glue.
And we're seeking $80,000
for 15% of our business.
Sharks, I have the solution
to stop those messy breakups.
I'm not talking about
your love life.
Duh.
[ Laughter ]
I'm talking about this.
‐No!
‐Oh, no.
You spent all day building
a masterpiece.
That's why I invented Le‐Glue,
the world's first
non‐permanent adhesive
that just dissolves in water.
Plus it's non‐toxic
and safe for kids.
After all, Le‐Glue is created
for kids by a kid.
[ Greiner chuckles ]
To use Le‐Glue, just apply
a little bit to each brick,
let it sit...
and you're good to go.
So the next time this happens...
...you just pick it
right on up...
[ Laughter ]
...and keep on playing.
And the best part ‐‐
just soak them in water,
and they come apart
like brand‐new again.
So, Sharks,
who wants to stick with me
and help me stop those messy
breakups with Le‐Glue?
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Alright.
Good job.
We have some samples
and some homemade sharks
that the kids
have made for you.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Thank you, Tripp.
‐Thank you, Allee.
‐Oh, I like.
I got a great white.
Nice dress.
Thank you.
We got you the whale shark
to match your ego.
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Nice.
Thank you, Tripp.
You're very wise.
Ba‐bam!
‐Good job, Tripp.
‐Thank you.
Thank you.
So, Tripp, I see you
have a patent there.
‐Yes, sir.
‐Oh, wow.
What did you patent on this?
Tripp: We have
a utility patent,
and my patent attorney told me
that I was one
of the youngest patent holders
in U. S. history.
‐Really?
‐Good for you.
‐How old are you?
‐12.
12.
That's pretty amazing.
I got the patent
when I was 10.
How did you figure this out,
Tripp?
In the third grade
as a class assignment,
I had the option
to write a paper
or come up with an invention,
and I think I chose
to do what any other logical
9‐year‐old would do ‐‐
avoided the writing.
[ Chuckling ]
So I went home and asked my dad,
"How in the world do I come up
with an invention?!"
He said it was simple ‐‐
just identify a problem and then
find a solution to fix it.
So, that's exactly
what I did.
Spot‐on.
As I was in my room,
playing with my airplane
and thinking about,
"What could I do?"
the wing would pop off
whenever I'd do a takeoff.
Then I knew what I should do.
I need something to hold
these bricks together
but not permanently
like superglue does.
Siminoff: So, Tripp,
as the only Shark who's been
on your side of the table,
I have to say,
great job with
your presentation.
Also, as someone who still has a
child that's in this age range,
I have to say this
is a real problem.
My feet, I think, have permanent
marks in them
from stepping on bricks,
so this Le‐Glu‐‐ Glue
could be a real lifesaver.
But tell me about the business.
Last year,
we sold $52,000...
‐Wow!
‐Good for you.
...and this year,
up until the end of May,
we've sold $32,000,
and in our whole lifetime,
we've sold just over $125,000.
Good for you.
‐How are you selling it, Tripp?
‐Wow.
Mostly online
on our own website.
What do you sell it for?
How much does it cost
to make a package?
It costs 43 cents with direct
labor, but don't tell anybody.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐But what do you sell it for?
‐What do you sell it for?
‐We sell it for $8.99.
‐That's a great margin.
‐Oh.
‐Good margins.
Tripp, why'd you decide to
create a business
out of this, though?
I mean, you could've
just aced the project,
right,
and got a good grade.
Even from a small age, I've
always watched "Shark Tank,"
and as soon as I actually
had a business,
one of the first things ‐‐
probably even the first thing ‐‐
I asked my dad was, "We have
to go on 'Shark Tank'."
‐[ Chuckling ]
‐That is good.
So, now I'm pretty much
living my dream.
‐Oh, that's so great.
‐Oh, good.
O'Leary: What is your vision in
terms of getting distribution?
You gonna leave it online, or do
you want to get it into retail
where building blocks
are sold?
His personal goal
is to partner
with one of the brick
manufacturers at some point
to be in every
one of the kits.
Tell you what,
I'm interested in the idea
of approaching
the big block guys.
I know
all the toy companies.
I want to help do something
that you're not doing,
which is get
a license deal.
So, I'd make
a contingency on it.
I'll give you the $80,000.
I'll go make those
calls for you,
but you're gonna
have to come with me
to pitch it to the CEO.
Now, you're gonna have to
put on
a black suit and tie,
just like me.
[ Laughter ]
A tie pin and everything.
That's how
it's gonna work.
You'll look like
a little undertaker.
Well, I have hair, so...
[ Laughter ]
O'Leary:
But the deal's this ‐‐
Whatever I get on the royalty
deal for all of us,
we're gonna go 50/50
until I get my 80K back,
'cause it's gonna be
a tremendous amount of work.
Then it's gonna
drop down to 20%,
and we're gonna have
a partnership in perpetuity
where I'm a 20% shareholder
of the company.
If I don't deliver the big guy,
then I don't have any stake.
We go together, we find out
if they're gonna do it,
they say yes,
we're in business.
Greiner: Wow.
Siminoff: Tripp, Allee,
I think you guys have done
an amazing job with this.
It's ‐‐ It is solving
a real problem.
Um, I think Mr. Wonderful
is actually being wonderful
on this one,
and I think it's a ‐‐
it's a great way to do it.
So, because of that,
I'm out.
Thank you for your time.
John: You know what?
I like this.
I think the licensing route
is great.
I think that
we should try that.
I don't know
as many of the toy companies.
However, I know
the adhesive giant, 3M.
They're doing $30 billion
a year in ‐‐ in adhesives.
So, I'm gonna offer you $80,000
for 25%.
Greiner:
Well, listen, Tripp.
You have two great offers
on the table
where I think either way,
you really can't lose.
So, I'm going out,
but congratulations.
Thank you so much.
Cuban: Guys, I think
it's a great product, too.
I think you have two great
offers on the table
that would be better
than what I can do.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
So, Tripp, you have to
make a decision.
Uh, Daymond, we would like
to make a counteroffer.
Uh, the $80,000 for 20%.
I would like to
stick at the 25%.
I would ‐‐ I would
normally ask 33%.
Are you planning to take him
to retail, as well?
Well, I'm planning to do
whatever you feel is best.
Or licensing. Okay.
Retail may or may not
be in your cards,
but that's something you guys
will decide after you,
you know, decide where
you want to go with it.
And, Mr. O'Leary,
the $80,000 ‐‐
When you're saying, "If you
can't make the deal..."
But I don't get any of your
company unless I deliver
the license deal at ‐‐
one that you want to do.
I'll be taking the same
toy guys, as well.
Greiner: The real difference
is contingency
‐on it happening and not.
‐Well, also...
It's ‐‐ It's success‐based,
though.
It's not a ‐‐
It's not a contingency.
It is. It is.
I don't get anything
if I don't deliver.
But the thing is, with Daymond,
it's firm.
But why give up
25% of your company
if you don't deliver
the whale shark?
That's what I say.
You decide.
Tell me what you want.
Okay.
Mr. O'Leary,
we'd like to do business.
‐Oh.
‐That's great.
‐Alright, Tripp.
‐Oh, my gosh.
‐Congratulations, guys.
Congratulations. You did really
well on the Tank, you know?
You got two offers.
That's pretty good.
Thank you.
Not easy to
get that done.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you so much, sir.
‐Thanks, guys. Congrats.
‐Thank you for your time.
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Nice job.
‐[ Chuckling ]
‐Oh.
Great kid, bad judge
of character.
Oh.
Success in the Tank.
Tripp:
Kevin's my favorite because
he doesn't sugarcoat things,
and I'm so excited to work
with him and move forward.
This is definitely
the best day of my life.
It shows you finally get
somebody to like you
if you grovel enough
to a 12‐year‐old.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a solution
to a growing
environmental problem.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Emma.
And my name's Miles.
We're offering 5% of our
company, FinalStraw,
for $625,000.
‐Ooh.
‐Whoo.
Sharks,
maybe you've noticed
that our oceans are filling up
with plastic trash.
Much of that trash is made of
a seemingly harmless item ‐‐
the plastic straw.
Straws may not seem
like a big deal to you,
but they're one of the top items
littering our beaches,
and some of the more sensitive
ocean creatures are pissed.
[ Laughter ]
What is this place?
Shark Tank!
Sharks? Oh, please.
Ah, you think sharks
are scary?
I'm more freaked out
by the 500 million straws
we use every day in the U. S.
Yeah. It's a big number
to get your head around.
Here's what it looks
like every second.
[ Greiner gasps ]
‐[ Laughing ] Oh!
‐Whoa!
Sharks,
this is 5,700 straws.
This is how many straws we use
every second in the U. S.
Wow.
Plastic straws
are going out of style.
They're getting banned in cities
and countries around the world.
We thought there had
to be a better way
to design
the drinking straw.
So we did.
This is FinalStraw.
FinalStraw is the world's first
reusable, collapsible straw.
It folds up and fits in a case
the size of a car key
and is small enough
to go on your key chain
or in your pocket.
The anti‐plastic‐straw movement
is growing rapidly,
and we are at
the forefront.
Sharks,
the mermaids need our help.
So, who wants to help us
suck responsibly?
We have samples?
We do.
We have samples.
‐Let's go.
‐Bye.
[ Laughter ]
Bye, mermaid!
Greiner: Very cute ‐‐
cute actress.
Emma:
We've got the Healthy Coral.
We've got Shark‐Butt Gray
for you.
‐Shark‐Butt Gray?
‐Shark‐Butt?
Yeah, and then you get
the Arctic‐melt Blue.
And this is our
Suck‐ulent Green.
‐Suck‐ulent Green.
‐Yep.
John: So, where did you get
all these straws from?
‐They're used straws, right?
‐A lot of these were found on ‐‐
Yeah.
These are all used straws.
‐Wow.
‐We've got an artist in Malibu
who's working on
an installation
to show the impacts of
single‐use plastic straws,
and she's been collecting
them from restaurants.
‐She turns it to art.
‐I got ‐‐ I got it.
She's turning this into art.
It's pretty clear
that this is a massive movement
you may have all seen.
There were some scientists
doing research on sea turtles,
and they found a turtle,
and they noticed something
in its nostril and found that
it was a full‐length straw
stuck up this
turtle's nose.
‐Wow.
‐What's your backgrounds?
Um, so, I just finished up
my master's at Harvard
in environmental management
and sustainability.
And while I was getting
my master's, I was working
at Los Alamos
National Laboratory
in waste minimization.
Oh, yeah, some just bobo
that fell off a truck.
[ Laughs ]
You know what
you're doing.
‐What's your background?
‐And, Miles?
Miles: My background is ‐‐
I was working on the straw.
We had a mutual friend.
This mutual friend said,
"Hey, you need to call
my friend Emma
because she's
the straw girl.
She hates plastic straws."
So, I called Emma up and learned
about her background
and that she had given a TEDx
talk on plastic straws.
How much does this cost to make?
$5.
So...
What do you sell it for?
$20.
‐$20.
‐Oh!
‐Too expensive.
‐It's expensive.
You came in asking
for $625,000 for 5%.
Now, typically, no one comes in
with that kind of ask
unless they have some kind
of sales to back that up.
We ‐‐ We've definitely sold
a few so far.
So, we launched this company
two months ago on Kickstarter.
We ran our Kickstarter for 30
days and raised $1.89 million...
Whoa.
...on Kickstarter.
So, have you shipped anything?
So, the Kickstarter will
fulfill in November.
Oh, okay.
And since we launched
on Kickstarter,
we started doing pre‐sales
on our website
and have done $15,000
a day in sales.
Really?
Guys, the world's largest
coffee chain
does 2 billion straws a year.
‐Yes.
‐Yep.
Now, they've started
to investigate using paper.
It increases their cost
by 4 1/2 times,
and they are in hot liquid.
They get very soggy
at the bottom.
Emma: So, first of all,
paper straws ‐‐
though they won't end up in
a turtle's nose like that,
it's still single‐use.
You still have to use a ton of
energy, a ton of water, and ‐‐
‐You got to do the same here.
‐You're absolutely ‐‐
You know what? No,
you're spot‐on about that.
Yeah.
I love the mission here,
but there's really dozens
and dozens of straws out there
to do what yours is doing.
Yours, I think, is clever and
good, but you haven't sold them
and gotten them into
people's hands yet.
I like a product to be in hand
and know that it's
really working.
I'm sorry, I'm out.
‐Thank you. Thanks, Lori.
‐Thanks, Lori.
O'Leary:
You're not really a company yet.
You're a mission with a product.
The only way this works for an
investor is to structure a deal
where they get their capital
back on a scheduled way.
Thought you'd say that.
Yes, he would say that...
Yeah. He would.
...'cause that's the only way
it's gonna work.
There's so much risk.
Here's an offer for you.
I'll do the $625,000.
I want 10%.
But I want a royalty
of $2 a straw
‐'cause you can afford it...
‐Whew.
Ooh.
...until I've got back...
$1.8 million.
So, I ‐‐ I get a return
on my money.
Okay.
Siminoff:
You have a great mission.
This problem needs
to be solved.
I mean, and ‐‐ and ‐‐ and seeing
these straws just ‐‐
It makes me sick.
One second.
This is one second.
It ‐‐ It's sickening.
Count to 60.
Yeah.
Well, what worries me, though,
is changing consumer behavior.
It's just, am I gonna carry
another box in my pocket?
Cuban: Well, it's not
just carrying it.
Before that, you've
got to educate them
and then get them to buy it.
Yeah.
So, for that, I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you, Jamie.
So, I love your cause, and you
are the Straw Whisperer,
it sounds like.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, listen, you're
talking about $20 straws.
Sure.
And, you know,
we're talking about
1% of the market
would buy this at $20.
The rest are sold
in commercial use.
This isn't for
commercial use.
This is for ‐‐
Right,
but that's my point.
I think that's your biggest
challenge here ‐‐
that 95% of the market are
really just trying to get straws
and not increase
their cost of living.
And that few will go to this,
and you're not gonna be able
to scale as big
as I think you can
for this valuation,
so I'm out.
We appreciate that.
Here's the thing
about $20 straws.
People spend $20
at Starbucks.
They spend it going out
on a Saturday night.
And what people say on our
reviews is, "Oh, my gosh,
I'm gonna save my money
to get this straw,"
because it's really
important to them.
Look, as you speak,
Sharks are dropping out.
Now, on "Shark Tank,"
when you have an offer
and the other options
start to go away,
the Shark that made you
the offer
starts to feel very frisky.
♪♪
Narrator: Three Sharks are out.
Emma and Miles have one offer
on the table from Kevin
for their reusable straw
company, FinalStraw.
John:
You got an offer here.
Did you guys like
Kevin's offer?
Um, so, Kevin.
We want a partner.
We want someone who's gonna,
you know, be in there with us.
We can't be bleeding
the company
out of money
right at the beginning.
So does that mean you're
rejecting him?
Why would I ‐‐
When I invest in a company,
do you think I go against them?
No, absolutely not.
Absolutely not.
But I think that ‐‐
All my companies,
look at all of them.
They've done
phenomenally well.
You want ‐‐
You want somebody ‐‐
You want somebody to be
in there with you for 5%?
Well, so we'd be
interested in, you know,
entertaining offers
at higher percentages, um...
Okay, I'll help you out.
I'll help you out, Emma,
'cause you're feeling
really bold.
Let her finish, let her finish,
let her finish.
Let me ‐‐ Let me talk
a little about my product.
I'll help you out.
[ Laughs ]
I'm out.
Ohh.
Good luck.
Cuban: Look,
I have lots of concerns.
Competition and knock‐offs,
first and foremost.
Mm‐hmm.
I'll make you an offer, but it's
gonna be a Sharky offer.
I'll give you
the $625,000,
but I want 25%
of the company
because I think you have
a lot of question marks
in terms of the business side,
the finances side.
Yeah.
The online side,
you seem to have
done pretty well.
Well, and I think to
the marketing, you know,
what is so cool
about our product
is people's passion
behind it.
He gave you an offer.
Yeah.
Don't talk your way
out of it.
Now we got to talk business.
No, I'm not gonna talk
my way out of it.
So, Mark, we really appreciate
your offer, you know.
The valuation you gave us
is $2 million,
and we've already done more than
that in sales in two months.
So, what we'd like
to offer you
is $625,000 for 12.5%.
No, thank you. I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
‐All the best, guys.
‐Good luck.
Greiner:
That was interesting.
O'Leary: They have no idea
what's ahead for them.
‐But sometimes ‐‐
‐They remind me of Bambi jumping
around in the forest
and then...
Siminoff: I think this
is an execution business.
‐The demand is 100% there.
‐It's marketing.
It's ‐‐ It's can you execute
against the other people
that are gonna try
to kill Bambi?
Wow, I can't believe
it's been 200 episodes
and five years since Scrub Daddy
first appeared on "Shark Tank".
"Shark Tank's"
not only changed my life,
but the lives of everybody
here at Scrub Daddy!
All: A decade of dreams!
Thanks, "Shark Tank"!
Whoo!
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is an accessory
to simplify life
for lovers of camping.
♪♪
Hello.
I am Heidi Santiago,
and this is
my brilliant husband.
I'm Cory Santiago, and we are
here from Spokane, Washington.
We are seeking $100,000
for a 20% stake in our business,
Bear Minimum.
We've created the next evolution
in camping cookware,
and we are changing the way
you eat outdoors.
Now, back in the olden days,
travelers would pack
their covered wagons
with pots and pans.
But they took up so much space
and weighed a ton.
Then came the invention
of the nesting pot,
but it was still so bulky.
Today, we have the Bear Bowl ‐‐
the cook pot
that folds flat.
[ Vocalizes ]
[ Laughter ]
The Bear Bowl
is a super‐small...
O'Leary: That's scary.
...lightweight, collapsible
cook pot,
and with just four folds
and two snaps...
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
...it's so simple
to put together,
you can even do it
during a bear attack.
Mostly.
[ Laughter continues ]
He's so cute.
The Bear Bowl is made
out of food‐grade,
flame‐resistant material,
and it comes
in three sizes.
And because
it opens flat,
it is the easiest
to clean.
So, we are looking
for a Shark
or Sharks who aren't
afraid of bears.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Alright.
We have some
samples for you.
‐Good.
‐Nice.
‐That was very good.
Now the bear's gonna wipe out
'cause he can't see.
Greiner: Super cute.
Oh, the bear gives it to us.
[ Laughing ]
Thank you.
We also have
a campground favorite
that's been warmed up on
a Bear Bowl ‐‐ hot chocolate.
Oh, thanks, Mr. Bear.
What.
‐Thank you.
‐Cooked in the Bear pot?
‐Correct.
Bear Bowl.
What is the material?
What's this?
It's a PTFE‐coated
fiberglass.
So, have you protected this with
some kind of utility patent?
We have a utility patent.
Granted?
Not granted yet, and ‐‐
Have you been
knocked off yet?
No.
‐Are you selling it yet?
‐Have you been to market yet?
We did a Kickstarter.
We started
with a $1,000 goal
and we reached $40,000
at the end of the campaign.
I'm so excited.
I figured it out.
It's really a puzzle.
So, this
is a metal bottom.
Correct.
So, that's where
the heat's gonna hit.
What's the highest temperature
this'll get to
before it could melt?
We're ‐‐ You know,
we're rating it at like 550.
The entire body
can take flame
but just not a lot
of direct flame.
It will not melt?
No.
Campers, of course,
love it,
but, you know, we have this
whole, wide market of ‐‐
Campers love
to buy stuff.
Yes, they do.
You know, like, have
you ever gone to one
of those camping stores?
They do...
Yeah.
...and they buy
everything there.
But the only reason I think
people go camping
‐is to buy stuff.
‐For the cool gear, and ‐‐
What's ‐‐ What's
your background?
I ‐‐ I've worked in
manufacturing most of my career.
I came to a crossroads
where I was out of a job.
My wife was just finishing up
a tour for, uh, Broadway.
‐National Broadway tour.
‐What show?
"Ragtime."
The Broadway musical.
"Ragtime?"
[ Vocalizing ]
See!
Very good, and I give
voice lessons.
[ Vocalizes ]
So, you are in theater?
Okay, so, I grew up
in the country.
When I graduated,
I married my husband,
who had three children, and then
we had two children together.
You have five kids?
Yeah.
Wow.
Where are you guys
at with it?
Like, how much did
you invest?
Everything's in.
We've earned about
just under $90,000
with the Kickstarter
and everything else
in mostly
crowdfunding.
And s‐‐ a bunch
of sweat equity.
But what's the number?
What's the number?
Hours and hours.
Not a lot of capital.
‐That's okay. No.
‐Yeah, no.
What we did was ‐‐
We don't have ‐‐ I'm working
five jobs to keep us ‐‐
I'm fascinated with
Wonder Woman here.
You are working five
part‐time jobs.
Really, she calling me
Wonder Woman.
There you go.
What are those jobs?
Um, I teach English to
Chinese children online.
[ Voice breaking ]
I give voice lessons. I, um...
Why is this so emotional
for you?
Can you share?
It just h‐‐ kind of
happened that ‐‐
We both were unemployed
at the same time.
Our ‐‐ We were both unemployed
The ‐‐ The big piece of it
that we're hesitant to share
is that we did bring
a product to market
back in 2008.
And we put everything ‐‐
every dime and penny into it.
And there was a...
[ Sighs ]
It was bad timing, but
we don't like to give up.
[ Sniffles ]
And our middleman ‐‐
long story short ‐‐
ran off with our money...
Oh, no.
...and we never
heard from him again.
[ Sniffles ]
And it was everything
we had.
Oh, I'm sorry.
You know, when you ‐‐
and which we learned.
We learned so much from it.
I don't want this to be
a victim story at all.
We are not giving up.
We will do whatever it takes,
and it's a great product.
And I ‐‐ I'm just
emotional...
Cuban: H‐Heidi ‐‐
No, it's a beautiful,
beautiful story.
...because you guys ‐‐
No, you guys are amazing.
I wish you weren't afraid
of telling that story
because,
as people stand here,
they will make this seem like
everything was so easy.
We go, "What the hell
are you here for?"
So now we know
why you're here,
because you went
through everything
and you still
got a passion.
Okay, so now I'm an investor.
You're asking me for $100,000.
Yes.
What's the plan?
So, the plan is, is we ‐‐
we have already now
set up with a manufacturer
overseas.
Okay.
Uh, yeah.
And they've delivered
product to you.
And they've given us some
prototype samples...
Oh.
...and now we're
waiting for ‐‐
So, you say you got
manufacturing nailed.
Yes, we got
manufacturing ‐‐
And what's the cost
to deliver it here?
$6.90 for the small ones.
So, it costs you 7 bucks to make
and land it here?
How much do you sell it for?
$29.90.
Greiner:
And that's the baby.
That's the baby.
O'Leary: $29.95 to...
All these numbers
are for the baby.
...but you're not going
to sell it to a retailer
or a wholesaler?
We can go distribution.
‐Camping stores.
‐Camping stores, yeah.
‐Yeah.
‐Online.
‐Um, social media, as well.
‐Have you gone to any shows ‐‐
camping shows and ‐‐
‐We haven't ‐‐
We haven't done
any shows yet.
‐Oh, you should.
‐Yeah, no, we ‐‐ Yeah.
You'll do amazing there.
It'll be ‐‐
It'll be great there.
So you got a lot of ‐‐
You got a lot of work ahead.
You don't ‐‐ It doesn't sound
like you got a plan yet.
‐We have a plan.
‐Yeah, no, yeah.
Siminoff: You know what I love
about you guys is ‐‐
is ‐‐ is, like ‐‐
We haven't even st‐‐
told our plan yet.
I went out there and built
a product and had no idea
what I was doing,
and I went to a consultant...
We are going to ‐‐ Yes.
...and they destroyed me...
Okay, good to know.
...just like you...
[ Laughter ]
...and could've easily,
you know, pulled up stakes,
but I kept going.
Yep.
And you guys are ‐‐
are still going.
And I love ‐‐ That experience
didn't stop you.
What I want to understand,
I think, more now is,
how do we execute against it?
So, we have, uh,
a distributor in Canada
who has relationships with all
the big‐box stores,
and we have online, and that's
what we're ‐‐ that's our goal.
And our marketing plan.
And then we're gonna do
a lot of marketing.
We need money to ‐‐
So, but also
what we're doing
is we're
building a brand.
Money's actually not
the answer, though.
I think you need to understand
how to put the money to work,
or else it's too easy
to get rid of.
Yeah.
Cuban:
Who's your business person?
‐We have a few.
‐Meaning what?
In the ‐‐
In the team, yeah.
We have advisers
in the business.
Do they own stock?
Yep.
They do. 10%.
Cory, are you ‐‐ are you working
full time on this?
This is my full‐time job.
Uh, I drive
for Lyft at night.
So, guys,
I never go to places
where there isn't
24‐hour room service,
and the idea of going outside
and being bitten by stuff...
So, I would never use
this product.
‐I'm out.
‐Okay.
Cuban:
You are passionate entrepreneurs
that love your product,
love everything about
what you're doing,
but you have one
fatal flaw.
It doesn't sound like you're
hard‐core business people.
I think it's a difficult
position to invest in.
So, for those reasons, I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you, Mark.
You guys have ‐‐ You have ‐‐
You have grit.
I‐I like the comeback thing
'cause I think it's ‐‐
The best university
you can go to is failure.
I love that you're a Lyft driver
because it shows you're willing
to do what it takes to ‐‐
to provide for your family and
make money, and I‐I love that.
Mm‐hmm.
I like
the camping sector.
I think there's a lot of growth
that you can do there.
I'd do $100,000 for 25%.
You should say yes
right now.
O'Leary: You should take
that deal so fast.
‐Wow.
‐Don't even think about it.
Are there any other offers?
Look, the bear's
jumping up and down.
Greiner:
Well, listen, the camping space
is not as much a passion
of mine,
and I think Jamie
relates to it better.
And for that reason, I'm out.
Lori.
Can I speak to that
for a second?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐You have an offer.
‐Just ‐‐ Just ‐‐
‐I would really be concerned
about whether or not
that offer disappears.
I have an offer.
O'Leary: Whoa.
♪♪
Narrator: Three Sharks are out.
Jamie has offered
$100,000 for 25%
of Heidi and Cory's collapsible
cooking pot, Bear Minimum,
but Daymond is also interested.
I deal with a lot
of online retailers
that sell
to the prepper community ‐‐
the people that think that
zombies are gonna attack
or the world's gonna end.
I have an offer for you,
but it's gonna be a little
Sharky, though.
$100,000 for 33%.
I don't know what Jamie
needs behind him,
but I know that I have a lot
of people in this area
that I'm going to have to
probably share percentages with,
but I want them to be able
to get the word out online ‐‐
all these social‐media
conversions.
So I have to have
a higher percentage
so I'm able to afford
to bring them to the party.
And let me just tell you, I ‐‐
What I like about this ‐‐
It enables us to go out more,
outdoors.
We need to get
our kids out.
Right. Right.
Yes.
This is like, you know, out ‐‐
out of the screens,
out of all this stuff.
I think this is a great thing
to get a mission behind
and really build.
Is it alright
if we take a minute?
One minute.
♪♪
‐Okay, guys.
‐Alright.
What are you gonna do?
I think we're gonna
take a deal with Jamie.
[ Clapping ]
Cuban:
Congrats, Jamie.
‐Thanks, guys.
‐Congrats, Jamie.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Thank you.
‐I'm setting the bear on fire.
‐Got to hug the bear.
‐Thank you, everybody.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Great job, great job.
Good luck.
‐Congrats, Jamie.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Thank you for your offer.
‐Of course.
‐Congrats.
‐Well, thank you.
O'Leary: Congratulations.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so ‐‐ I'm so fascinated
with the bear here.
[ Laughs ]
You cried like a baby.
[ Voice breaking ] I want other
people to ‐‐ who are out there.
I know you're out there
and you're, you know,
sitting, wondering why
it happened to you
when you were so careful
and you wanted to give up.
Don't ever give up.
Believe in yourself.
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪